[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 et que nous allons nous
intéresser au recrutement à saint
quentin en yvelines avec plus de 3
millions de chômeurs en france et un
gouvernement qui souhaite inverser la
courbe du chômage le recrutement est
devenue un enjeu majeur nous verrons
donc comment l'agglomération tire son
épingle du jeu alors comment mieux
recruter à saint-quentin sommaire focus
sur le premier séminaire sur le
recrutement qui s'est déroulée le 17
octobre à saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif de l'événement faire bouger
les lignes nous ferons un point et puis
nous découvrirons l'entreprise 4dconcept
7 de cette société de conseil aux
entreprises qui ne cesse d'évoluer se
confronter aux réalités du recrutement
nous verrons avec l quelles sont ces
outils et puis nous recevrons sandrine
corbin directrice de l'entreprise corbin
sas nous verrons avec elle les
contraintes liées à l'entreprise mais on
ne peut parler de recrutement sans
parler des chiffres du chômage en france
il ya 3 5 millions de chômeurs le 25
octobre dernier nous avons appris qu'ils
étaient en vie que le chiffre est en
baisse de 1,9 pour cent au niveau
national et saint quentin et les
yvelines tirent leur épingle du jeu avec
moins 2,2 pour cent fin août on
comptabilisait
65000 780 personnes inscrites à pôle
emploi aujourd'hui ils ne sont que 64
milles et pour cause
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses seize
mille établissements français et
internationaux et près de 145 mille
emplois dans des secteurs d'activité
diversifiés c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien après la
défense est le premier pôle commercial
des yvelines alors comment les
entreprises vont réussir à recruter
comment aider les jeunes à retourner sur
le chemin de l'emploi la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines a mis en place un
séminaire le 17 octobre dernier pour
répondre à ces questions
reportage d'anne laure l'anguille
une petite centaine de formateurs
recruteurs et entreprises du territoire
sont venus échanger leurs idées ce matin
si les yvelines reste un département
dynamique il n'en demeure pas moins dans
les moyennes nationales avec un taux de
chômage d'environ 10% en cause notamment
la difficulté des entreprises à trouver
des candidats la plupart des entreprises
en tout cas ce qu'on a constaté
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles ont des
besoins de recrutement donc d'emploi
c'est-à-dire des besoins réels d'emploi
et qu'elles nous ont beaucoup de
difficultés pour trouver des personnes
correspondant à ces emplois c'est
surtout dans les métiers innovants ou
émergents que trouver un collaborateur
reste difficile
island de chaudronnier voilà par exemple
ça c'est pas un mec est innovant non
c'est un métier convergent à nouveau
face à cela l'agglomération de saint
quentin qui organise cette journée se
focalise sur l'orientation aiguiller les
jeunes vers un métier qui leur plaît et
pour lequel existe une demande réelle
des entreprises voilà l'étape
essentielle pour recréer de l'emploi
vous ne pouvez pas imposer à des jeunes
dans les filières générales s'ils n'ont
pas envie ce n'est pas possible vous ne
pouvez pas dire à un jeune il faut que
tu fasses un bac s parce que c'est bien
pour toi ce n'est pas possible par
contre il faut également que ce jeune
n'a soit conscient qu'il ya des filières
techniques
cette journée autour de la formation va
permettre deux actions la création d'un
observatoire des métiers émergents et
l'organisation de rendez vous annuel
avec l'ensemble des centres de formation
du territoire objectif prévoir les défis
d'avenir
faisons un point maintenant sur
l'entreprise 4dconcept située à montigny
le bretonneux cette pme est une promesse
aider les entreprises et les doter de
systèmes documentaires entre autres des
promesses innovante qui ne peuvent être
faites sans l'aide de collaborateurs
aguerris alors comment cas des concepts
recrute reportage d'anne laure
l'anguille
4dconcept est une entreprise prestataire
en informatique les 50 collaborateurs de
la société travaille à saint quentin en
yvelines lyon ou encore toulouse
c'est pour cette raison que le
recrutement est très important pour
l'entreprise qui ne cesse de s'agrandir
mais recruter n'est pas simple la
difficulté pour nous c'est de
d'intéresser les candidats à travailler
dans une pme il faut savoir que beaucoup
de ss2i ou de grosses entreprises
appelées les ingénieurs qui sortent de
l'école
parce que ils ont déjà le côté grands
comptes grand client ou alors dans une
ss2i aussi vous faites partie d'une une
grosse
entreprise qui va vous permettre de
travailler à différents endroits pour
différents clients donc qui peut être
aussi une source d'expérience pour les
jeunes candidats donc trouver des
candidats qui s'intéresse à une pme
c'est un peu plus dur quand ils sont
jeunes pour remédier à ces difficultés
pour recruter des candidats comme des
ingénieurs informatiques l'entreprise
utilise plusieurs solutions elle fait
appel à des cabinets de recrutement
poste des annonces sur internet ou use
des réseaux sociaux ce qui permet aussi
à l'entreprise 4dconcept d'affiner sa
sélection elle souhaite s'exporter à
l'international
c'est potentiellement ce projet que nous
avons devant nous quel développement à
l'international et qui pourrait nous
amener à faire un développement plus
important que celui que nous avions
prévu de faire avec entre autres la
compétence de langue également puisque
en fait dans nos outils il ya toujours
besoin d'un accompagnement chez nos
clients donc en fait on installe des
solutions chez nos clients et ont fait
l'accompagnement la formation la mise en
oeuvre est institué et donc en fait nos
collaborateurs doivent aller faire ses
accompagnements chez les clients donc
forcément le l'international nécessitera
en fait également la maîtrise de la
langue
l'entreprise réalise une croissance de
15 à 20% par an avec une telle évolution
le recrutement est un défi majeur pour
la pme qui souhaitent continuer à offrir
aux entreprises un service de qualité
alors vous avez pu le voir dans le
reportage recruter n'est pas toujours
facile alors quelles sont les
contraintes nous allons en discuter avec
sandrine corman directrice de
l'entreprise corbin sas c'est une
entreprise qui propose comme service
d'entretenir rembobinez ou remplacez vos
machines tournantes bonsoir madame
corbin je pense avoir donné toutes les
missions de votre entreprise j'avais
oublié on intervient sur site pour aider
donc
aux clients à entretenir leur moteur
électrique ou ce que le moteur
électrique entraîne donc ça peut aller
de du chauffage dans le tertiaire ou
moteur dans les piscines date est vaste
comme par rapport au recrutement
question large quels sont vos
contraintes aujourd'hui
alors nous au niveau du recrutement on
est une petite entreprise on est moins
de 10 il ya six salariés six techniciens
et j'ai une assistante on a des
des techniciens qui ont entre qui ont
plus de 20 ans ou voir plus de dix ans
d'ancienneté donc on ne recrute pas tous
les jours donc ce n'est pas notre métier
est de fait
on est un petit peu déconnecté des
évolutions donc sur ces dernières années
quand on a été amené à recruter on a
fait appel à des cabinets de recrutement
est donc la contrainte c'est surtout une
contrainte financière pour nous bon il y
a en tout cas un accompagnement qui nous
a aidés à trouver un technicien en 2013
qu'est ce que ça apporte en plus de
faire appel à un cabinet safin la
recherche ou est ce que c'est devenu
compliqué c'est quand même un secteur de
technologie de pointe ce que vous faites
c'est difficile de trouver des personnes
disons que passer par un cabinet de
recrutement ça permet d'affiner les
recherches
et puis c et disons dans leur domaine de
faire des sélections une petite
entreprise
le dirigeant a quand même des
difficultés à passer beaucoup de temps
sur sur un recrutement et ne pas se
tromper
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour nous puisque vous dit on est moins
de 10 6 pour recruter une personne qui
ne convient pas ça peut en tout cas
pendant quelques temps désorganisé
l'entreprise et si donc les caisses mais
qu'est ce que vous avez pu voir par
rapport au secteur du recrutement vous
recrutent chez les personnes est ce que
les jeunes sont assez fort mais déjà par
rapport à votre secteur alors nous en
fait on a la chance d'être près de
l'école qui forme dans nos types de
métiers par exemple nous on travaille
pas mal avec le lycée des métiers louis
blériot à trappes et nous avons un
technicien qui est venu chez nous en
stage en 1995 il est encore chez nous
nous avons donc depuis
pas cessé de d'avoir ou des stagiaires
ou dans d'autres cas l'alternance aussi
c'est une bonne bonne bonne possibilité
pour rencontrer des jeunes et puis pour
les attirer aussi dans nos métiers parce
que tu travailles le pourtant invité
celle du travail on en a pas de problème
il ya des craintes
pour les personnes et encore cette
mauvaise image c'est quelque chose que
vous avez pu voir durant les
recrutements ou autour de vous alors les
gens nous qu'on rencontre les jeunes la
plupart ont quand même décidé de deux de
leurs voies de formation
par contre il est vrai que quand vous
avez un élève à moi même mon fils s'est
orientée
en bac professionnel
je dirais que l'image quand vous êtes au
collège et que vous partez vers une
orientation
vous êtes un petit peu mis de côté au
sein des collèges il n'y a pas cette
volonté en france 2 d'aider les jeunes
qui ne souhaitent pas aller dans les
études générales à trouver leur voie
c'est c'est quand même assez compliqué
et puis et puis les mentalités voilà si
au niveau des organismes faut parler de
pôle emploi vous sentez qu'il ya quand
même un accent qui est tourné vers
l'industrie comprennent vos demandes
ou pas plus que ça je sens que en fait
on a eu un recrutement assez malheureux
il ya un peu plus de dix ans avec pôle
emploi et donc voilà je n'ai pas même à
c'est un assez mauvais souvenir
mais je peux pas je peux pas dire que je
ne pourrais pas nous aider après on se
tourne pas
automatique voilà avait eu non plus
comme je vous dis on recrute pas non
plus
enfin régulièrement au sein de notre
entreprise là nous avons recruté un
jeune est en fait on s'est rencontré en
discutant avec un des clients en fait un
nouveau client et il me parlait de son
fils qui cherchait du travail qui n'en
trouvait pas et il s'avère que c'était
le profil que nous on
recherchait est en fait le plus
important dans le recrutement chez nous
c'est trouver quelqu'un de motivé pour
avoir envie d'apprendre le métier parce
que on peut apprendre des choses à
l'école en pratique par exemple les bacs
pros maintenant ont quand même sur les
trois années
voilà ils ont quand même voilà pas mal
de deux périodes de stage et donc ça
permet d'avoir en plus de leurs
pratiques à l'école une pratique terrain
qui est importante mais c'est nous qui
formons quand même in fine et nos
salariés à la spécifité de de notre
métier de notre entreprise est au niveau
de l'agglomération qui vous sentez qu'il
ya une aide par rapport au recrutement
il vous avez des outils pour aider alors
sur ces dernières années moi j'ai j'ai
rencontré
une personne en charge des ressources
humaines pour les petites entreprises
comme nous puisque nous on n'a pas de
deux directions des ressources humaines
ou de service des ressources humaines
sept dirigeants qui doit être à même de
connaître beaucoup de choses et on
demande beaucoup aux dirigeants quand
même des petites entreprises
et de fête voilà moi j'avais fait appel
et on s'était rencontrés il y avait eu
des petites formations aussi
ponctuel donc vous pouvez dire que la
lave et de 50 ans en gros vous vous aide
je pense qu'il ya une volonté en tout
cas d'aidé et de mettre à disposition
d'entreprises telles que là nous de voir
de grands puisqu'on avait fait un petit
déjeuner
j'ai bien compris en tout cas je vous
remercie madame corbin et c'est un sujet
vraiment très important on passe
maintenant à l'agenda
deux dates sont à noter dans votre
agenda
agenda on commence avec la semaine des
métiers de la finance qui se déroule du
7 au 10 novembre c'est à la cité des
métiers de trappes durant ces journées
des conférences et des job dating sont
organisées
on passe à la journée recrutement cette
journée a pour but de permettre à des
candidats de rencontrer des entreprises
lors d'entretiens cela se déroule le 17
novembre au salon antoine de
saint-exupéry à coignières 7,8 échos
c'est fini on se retrouve dans 15 jours
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]